as housing secretary i'm going to set
out our comprehensive plan
to safely restart reopen
and renew the housing market but first i
want to update you
on the latest data on the coronavirus
response
million ninety four thousand two hundred
and nine tests
for coronavirus have now been carried
out in the united kingdom
including 87 063 tests
carried out yesterday two hundred and
twenty nine
thousand seven hundred and five people
have tested positive that's an increase
of three thousand
two hundred and forty two cases
since yesterday eleven thousand
three hundred and twenty seven people
are in hospital
with covid 19 down fifteen percent
from thirteen thousand two hundred 273
cases
last week and sadly of those
tested positive for coronavirus across
all settings 33
186 have now died
that's an increase of 494 fatalities
since yesterday these figures include
deaths in
all settings not just in hospitals
before turning to the housing market i
want to
remind people of how we will address
this phase
of our fight against covid19
firstly and if we could turn to the
first slide thank you
in order to monitor our progress we're
establishing
a new covid alert level system
with five levels each relating to the
level of threat
posed by the virus the alert level will
be based primarily on the r value
and the number of coronavirus cases
and in turn that alert level will
determine the level of social distancing
measures in place the lower the level
the fewer the measures the higher the
level the stricter
the measures the social distancing
measures remain critical
in our efforts to control the virus
throughout the period of lockdown which
started in march the 23rd
we've been at level four meaning a
covert 19 epidemic
is in general circulation and
transmission
is high or rising exponentially
thanks to the hard work and the
sacrifices of the british people in the
lockdown
we've helped to bring the r level down
now that we are in a position to begin
moving to level three we will do so
in time in careful steps
if we turn to slide two we've set out
the first of three steps we'll take
to carefully modify the measures and
gradually
ease the lockdown and begin to allow
people
to return to their way of life but
crucially
doing so while avoiding what would be a
disastrous
second peak that could overwhelm the nhs
after each step we will closely
monitor the impact of that on the r
and the number of infections and all the
available data
will be used and we'll only take the
next step
when we're satisfied that it's
completely safe to do so
the first step from this week will be as
follows
those who cannot work from home should
now speak to their
employer about going back to work
you can now spend time outdoors and
exercise as often as you like
you can meet one person outside your
household
in an outdoor public place provided that
you stay
two meters apart the second step
from the first of june at the earliest
as long as the data
allows we will aim to do the following
primary schools to reopen for some
pupils
in smaller classes non-essential retail
to start to reopen when and where
it's safe to do so cultural and sporting
events
to take place behind closed doors
without crowds
and then step three no earlier than the
fourth of july
and again only if the data says
it's safe to do so we aim to allow the
following
more businesses and premises to open
including potentially those offering
personal care
such as leisure facilities public places
and places of worship and on that last
point
i've been speaking to faith leaders and
will convene later this week a task
force
to establish when and how places of
worship
can open safely for some of the
practices
where social distancing can take place
such as private
prayer potentially private prayer
being able to be carried out earlier
than july the fourth
many of these businesses and
organizations
will need to operate in new ways to
ensure that they're safe
and we will work with those sectors and
individuals
on how to do this if we turn to the
third slide
having taken the first step in carefully
adjusting
some of the measures and our advice to
people on what to do
we've also updated what we are asking
people
to do which is to stay alert
to control the virus and to save lives
for many people the appropriate course
still means staying at home as much as
possible but there are a range of
other actions we're advising people to
take
when they do go out to work or for other
activities limiting contact
with other people keeping distance when
you do go out
two meters apart wherever possible
washing your hands
regularly wearing a face covering when
you're in an enclosed space where it's
difficult
to be socially distant for example in
some shops or on public transport
and if you or anyone in your household
has symptoms
you all need to self-isolate
this slide sets out some of the
activities you can
now do and as i'll come on to later
you'll see
that you can now move house
on the fourth slide if everyone stays
alert and follows these rules we can
control coronavirus by keeping the r
down and reducing the number of
infections
this is how we will continue to save
lives
and livelihoods and we can begin as a
nation
to recover from coronavirus and as we
begin to recover
it's essential that we cautiously
open up parts of our economy where
it's safe to do so
now earlier today in parliament i made a
statement
setting out our clear coherent
and comprehensive plan to restart
reopen and renew the housing market
and our construction industry i'm sure
this will be of interest to many people
at home who are hoping to move house and
i'd like to set
out what this means in more detail
from today anyone in england can move
house
if they follow the new guidance that
we've published
on gov dot uk when the lockdown was
announced in march we changed the rules
so that people could only move home if
they thought it was reasonably
necessary that meant that more than 450
000 buyers had to put their plans
on hold and each month 300
000 tenancies come up for renewal as
well
a significant proportion of these will
result
in people needing to or wanting to move
home
the pressure to move for some was
becoming acute
with serious legal and financial
and health implications during
an already difficult time these people
have been stuck
in limbo now they can carry on with
their house moves
and add some certainty to their lives
so from today estate agents offices
can reopen viewings whether virtual
or in person are permitted show homes
can open and removal companies and the
other
essential parts of the sales and the
lettings process
are restarted with immediate effect
for most people moving home is not a
luxury
people decide to move home because their
personal circumstances
change the changes that i've announced
today are happening
safely in order to control the virus
and to protect the public we've
published very detailed
guidance informed by public health
advice
to explain how this can be achieved with
all parties
observing hygiene measures and social
distancing guidelines people have asked
why would they be able to look around a
stranger's home
but not visit their parents or loved
ones
at home now i understand why
this may seem confusing at first glance
especially when people have been
separated
from their loved ones for so long but
our guidelines
make clear that in the first instance
viewings
should happen virtually when viewings do
happen in person
we've set out a clear plan to ensure the
safety
of everybody involved in the property
itself those considering moving in and
the estate agents
and letting agents these requirements
include
visits being by appointment only open
house viewings
should not be taking place and
speculative
viewings where buyers or tenants are not
serious yet
are highly discouraged all parties
should follow
strict social distancing guidelines all
internal doors
should be opened where possible the
current occupier should vacate the
property
for the duration of the visit going out
for their daily exercise
going out to the shops or standing in
the garden if that's possible
all involved in the process should wash
their hands upon entering the property
and once the viewing has taken place all
the surfaces in the property including
the door handles
should be thoroughly cleaned there are
of course
exceptions for those who are
self-isolating
or have coronavirus they should not be
moving
or going back to work or allowing trades
people
or professionals into their home where
this is the case
all parties involved in house buying
or selling should prioritize amicable
sensible arrangements to change the move
dates
for the individuals concerned that's
been happening across the country
in recent weeks and it will need to
continue
we would also ask those who are
clinically vulnerable
and those who are shielding to consider
very carefully
their personal situation and to seek
personal
and specific medical advice before
deciding
whether to commit to or to proceed with
moving home
if you're in this situation and you
decide that you must go ahead
all professionals involved should be
made aware
so they can put in place any additional
precautionary measures
to provide further protection for your
health
and further legal protection to make
sure that the transaction
goes as smoothly as can be expected
a vibrant housing market means more than
buying and selling homes
we need to get building again and
britain
needs that it's something that this
government has always been committed to
something that our ambitious first homes
program will do
later this year with a 30 discount on
new homes for key workers
including nurses and teachers and police
officers as well as local
first-time buyers we want them to be
ready
as soon as possible and that's just one
of the reasons
why i'm keen to get construction up and
running
to help with this i'm today announcing
further steps
to support safe house building by
allowing more flexible working hours
on construction sites where it's
appropriate and with local
uh consent i'm allowing sites to apply
to extend their working hours again with
immediate effect
to 9 p.m monday to saturday in
residential areas
and beyond that in non-residential areas
and setting out
a very clear government position that
these applications should be approved by
local councils
unless there are very compelling reasons
not to do so
varied start and finish times will make
it much easier
for sites to observe social distancing
take the pressure
off public transport like the tube in
london
and keep britain building there are
countless examples
of the industry behaving responsibly and
proactively
during this pandemic i'd like to thank
today taylor wimpey
who have now got construction safely
underway
on the majority of their site and has
started removing staff
from the furlough scheme and getting
back to work on full pay
they are offering a discount of 5
for nhs staff and care workers on new
homes a great way
to recognize the contribution that our
frontline heroes
are making across the country so thank
you
to them it's also time
that the planning system makes more use
of
digital technology to operate remotely
and efficiently during this pandemic i'm
determined
that the planning inspectorate is at the
forefront
of this work and i welcome the
inspectorate now undertaking its first
ever virtual hearings i'm asking them to
make
all hearings virtual within weeks so the
planning system
can resume and be made more permanently
accessible
and user-friendly this is the most
comprehensive
restarting of an industry in the first
phase
of our roadmap with few if any
transactions
there is no visibility and no precedent
with which to accurately judge the state
of the housing market but history tells
us
that in every economic recovery in
modern british economic life the housing
market
has been key to recovery
and revival as housing secretary
i will do everything i can to support
the millions of people
employed in the construction and the
housing industries
to help their sector bounce back world's
always
prioritizing their safety and well-being
almost 100 separate organizations have
already signed up to the charter for
safe
working practice pledging that they will
share the responsibility to ensure that
their sites
operate safely and in accordance with
government
advice i'd like to thank all of those
who signed and encourage the whole
industry
to join them today
we reopen we restart and we renew the
housing market
and the construction industry to protect
lives
to save jobs and to begin rebuilding
our economy thank you